I'm Miss Minutes and it's my job to
catch you up so let's not waste
another minute settle in sharpen
your pencils and check this out
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie happy Marvel
phase five Marvel just released a new trailer to
Herald the beginning of Marvel Phase 5 the end
of Marvel phase four so we'll break down what
the overarching story is how it's building into
Avengers 5 King Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos of course I'll do videos
for all this stuff we're also doing an IMAX
movie ticket giveaway for Ant-Man and the boss
quantumania since it's coming out next all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber just post
all your Marvel Phase 5 theories in the comments
as you probably guessed the reason why they
had missed minutes narrate the Marvel Phase
5 trailer is because she's going to continue to
be a big character not only in Loki season 2 but
also Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty I really hope that
they actually use Miss minutes to narrate the
first trailer for Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty that'd
be a good way of telling the Avengers that they're
gonna have to take an L on that one like oh we're
all screwed Miss minutes is back Ant-Man and the
Wasp quantumania is meant to be the beginning of
Marvel phase five and that's why they're starting
off going so hard with Kang the Conqueror like he
is going to stomp Ant-Man and like a literal ant
everybody thinks about that scene from The
Avengers an ant has no quarrel with a boot
you planning to step on us and boot they want to
let you know that is getting real and that's why
they're starting off with a movie like this I
will talk a little about Marvel Phase 6 movies
during this because Avengers 5 and Avengers
6 are Marvel Phase 6 movies and the reason
there's no Spider-Man movie in Marvel Phase 5 on
the schedule here they announced a Comic-Con is
because if you've been keeping track of all the
dates of all the Marvel Phase 5 movies in series
you zoom in enhance on when Captain America
4 and the Thunderbolts movie are coming out
here Spider-Man 4 isn't actually going to be
released until 2025. they're reportedly going
into production at the end of this year with Tom
Holland coming back as you'd expect it's going
to be more of a street level Spider-Man movie
like Amazing Spider-Man comic book type of movie
really hoping they bring Daredevil back for a big
role during that Kingpin 2. Kingpin vs Spider-Man
would be awesome in the movies and currently on
the schedule Deadpool 3 in November 2024 is meant
to be the first Marvel Phase 6 movie so that
means that Spider-Man 4 is going to be a Marvel
Phase 6 movie originally Thunderbolts was meant
to be the end of Marvel Phase 5 as of Comic-Con
but then they move the blade move movie after
Thunderbolts that's coming out September 2024
and now that's the end of Marvel phase five but
the big difference between Marvel phase 4 and
Marvel Phase 5 is that Marvel phase 4 was kind
of the we're trying stuff out like expanding the
universe kind of phase combined with a little bit
of the covid crunch if you don't know what that
is basically what happened is because of the virus
shutdowns there were all these delays with all the
movies so a lot of people were trying to finish
effects and cobbled together movies as quickly
as they could and that's one of the reasons why a
lot of the material just in general not just from
Marvel but from all movie studios released the
last couple of years just felt weaker in general
just on the whole than movies released before
that or after that the next couple of years
so for example if it seems like Avengers 5 and
Avengers 6 are coming relatively soon the whole
idea is that Marvel phase 4 was never meant to
last for that long kovid shut everything down
originally it would have been like half as long
as it was before so a lot of it was just marvel
spinning its Wheels getting ready to do the really
cool stuff in Marvel Phase 5 and Marvel phase six
which is why it seems like Marvel Phase 5 is
rolling so much harder than Marvel phase 4 was
and during phase 5 it's meant to create the need
for the new Avengers team to form officially and
for that to start to happen in Captain America 4
New World Order like that movie is meant to be our
first official look on screen at the new Avengers
actually meeting together but there will be Easter
eggs and teasers before that like we've already
had a couple teasers there's still a couple
Avengers who survived Avengers end game and are
working together on teams together we saw in the
chunkshi post credit scene but according to Kevin
feige and the Marvel producers in present-day MCU
after Avengers end game The Avengers don't really
exist as an actual team in the classic sense
they're all kind of off doing their own thing and
some of them just happen to be helping the others
in an unofficial capacity really good example
is Bruce bannerhulk helping out Wong and Captain
Marvel try to figure out what's going on with the
10 rings I just did a video about that too because
based on the symbols of the 10 rings and the
symbols on Kangs' devices it seems like Kang built
the 10 rings of power in Miss Marvel's bangles and
that's where the signal inside them is committing
to back decaying in the quantum realm I'll post a
link to that longer video in the description below
because it's actually a pretty cool connection the
way they're weaving some of this stuff together
the second big goal of Marvel Phase 5 is tied
to the new Avengers forming but it's all about
the dark rain inspired Arc that's going to spin
out of secret Invasion basically like a rise of
the villains Arc across all of Marvel Phase 5
movies and Disney plus Series in all the chaos
that that's going to bring to the hero's lives
that's why it seems like Kang is rolling so hard
on Ant-Man during the Ant-Man the Wasp quantumania
trailer because it's the rise of Kang and he's
like our first big villain he's going to be the
overarching villain replacing Thanos basically
secret invasion is the first Marvel Phase 5
series which sets off more of an earth-based
version of that like rise of the villains plot
within earth in an adaptation of the comic
storyline where a group of evil Scrolls try to
take over the planet Nick Fury works with Talos,
Olivia Coleman is playing a version of Union Jack
from the comics and I believe the report is that
Emilia Clarke is playing Taylor's daughter she's a
scroll to one of the good ones and that's why she
looks human in the trailer she's just pretending
to be a human in all these scenes and I believe
she's involved with one of the evil Scrolls and
that's how she gets involved with the plot in the
comics dark Reign was the arc that came out of
secret Invasion all the heroes the villains on
Earth worked together to defeat the Scrolls
like it's us planet Earth versus the Scrolls
so it doesn't matter if you're a hero or villain
we need to work together a kind of situation but
it was Norman Osborne who took all the credit
for defeating the Scrolls because he landed the
kill shot on the scroll Empress it was captured
on video by every news Outlet on the planet so
everybody on the planet wound up seeing it and he
wrote that wave of popularity that he got from it
to take over Shield he took over Iron Man's Armory
and repurposed it into his Iron Patriot armor and
it was the beginning of villains ruling the planet
but doing it above board in the light of day like
Norman Osborne replaced the Avengers with his own
dark Avengers that were all stabbier anti-hero
or full-blown villain versions of the characters
it'd be like replacing the Avengers with a bunch
of ex-cons way more hardcore waist stabbier than
the regular Avengers they collectively exploited
their positions their power to their own personal
gain turned Earth into something akin to a fascist
police state basically and interestingly enough
the end of comic book dark Reign like the end
of Norman Osborne's reign of terror so to speak
happened when he tried to invade new Asgard which
was on earth like it is in the movies against the
expressed orders of the U.S president the century
wound up going full void after his dark Persona
took over destroyed New Asgard and then Thor
wound up killing him in the aftermath that the
U.S president wound up firing Norman Osborne and
replacing him with Steve Rogers Captain America
and it became the beginning of the heroic age of
Marvel which is sort of like a rebirth era for
all the heroes coming back and trying to make
everything right in the world again so they're
kind of doing a version of this in the MCU just
swapping some of the characters and adapting some
of the story so that it fits with what they've
already done they're giving all the Norman Osborne
plot to Thunderbolt Ross who they've recast with
Harrison Ford if you didn't hear about it because
William Hurt passed away recently and they met
and literally have these big plans for Thunderbolt
Ross and they don't want to just give that to
another character so now what's happening during
their MCU version of dark reign in the wake of
secret invasion is that Thunderbolt Ross will
eventually become the president of the United
States by the events of Captain America 4 and also
by then he will have been turned into the Red Hulk
they had a couple Easter eggs for this during
She-Hulk and I've talked a little bit about the
things that they're pulling together for this
for instance the leader is the main villain of
Captain America 4 in the comics he was part of
the Intelligentsia with Modoc who they're also
introducing in Ant-Man the wasp quantumania and
they're the ones that actually turn Thunderbolt
Ross into Red Hulk I don't know if they're
going to bring modok back in Captain America
4. that would actually be pretty cool but I think
they have plans to have the leader be one of the
people to turn Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hulk in
the MCU a lot of the Marvel phase 4 movies and
series have had teasers that they'll pay off in
Marvel phase five some of it they won't pay off
fully till Marvel phase six like a lot of it is
teasing Kang the Conqueror but the whole idea is
that MCU Thunderbolt Ross and Val seize way more
power in the the United States in the wake of
secret Invasion she's already the director of the
CIA as a black panther wakanda forever which makes
her incredibly powerful to begin with in what
Thunderbolt Ross becomes president they basically
take control of Congress and start doing whatever
they want just using the power however they want
like blank check Val do whatever she wants to do
she's also continuing the weapons plus program
which is where the century is coming from he's
meant to be the main villain of the Thunderbolts
movie and he's one of the weapons Plus in the
comics and reportedly they're also introducing
adamantium on tiamat's body the celestial that's
jutting out of the Indian Ocean they're finally
paying off that eternal's ending and she'll use
the Thunderbolts to try and go still like it
turns into a race of Nations to try and claim
all the celestial resources available there
because the celestial body would just be brimming
with all kinds of resources for people to exploit
and they'll probably wind up using some of the
adamantium that they steal to create a new MCU
version of weapon x with a new actor later on in
Marvel phase 7. I do think that they'll wait till
after Hugh Jackman comes back in Deadpool 3 in
Avengers 2 Wars as his Wolverine to debut a new
actor as MCU Wolverine I still think that they're
going to wait till after Avengers Secret Wars to
do the X-Men reboot movie which means Marvel phase
7 and Marvel phase 7 will also be the beginning of
a totally different Saga remember soco's Infinity
Saga which is all about The Infinity Gauntlet and
Thanos for Marvel face one through three then
the Multiverse Saga is Marvel phase 4 through
Marvel Phase 6 all about Kang and his variants I
think the next Saga Marvel phase 7 to phase 9 is
either going to be a new version of the Phoenix
Saga because of all the X-Men stuff that they're
gonna do after Secret Wars it'll be like a much
larger universe spanning storyline closer to
what you saw during X-Men the Animated Series
but with all the other Avengers characters too
or they could delay that like wait to do Phoenix
Saga and do a Galactus Saga before that because
I do think that they're waiting on doing Galactus
longer so they can do a much bigger Longer version
of the character and he won't just be like
a one-off Fantastic Four villain for example
for those of you that are eager to see Galactus
they're actually deleted scenes from Thor love
and thunder that had Jane Foster's Thor fighting
a version of Galactus like this looks just like
Galactus so it sounds like they were going to use
him in some comedic way and I'm kind of glad that
the scene didn't wind up in the movie no one
wants to see them do Galactus dirty again like
they did in the original Fantastic Four movies but
as we get more trailers and teasers for everything
that's happening in Marvel Phase 5 and phase six
of course I'll do more videos if you have any big
questions about what's going on just enjoy like
the bigger storylines or bigger villains just
write them Below in the comments I've got a couple
big videos that I'm working on for Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 more Ant-Man the wasp quantumania
and Kang videos Everyone click here for that
brand new trailer video and click here for my new
Mandalorian season 3 trailer video and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!